welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
post-credits scenes of thor love and
thunder scenes that i almost missed
because the ending of this movie had me
in tears everyone sitting next to me
were like hey dry those tears you big
baby they're about to give us some
easter egg yum yums at the world we'll
need you to explain how it all connects
to ant-man and yes for those of you
watching spoilers ahead don't watch this
video without seeing the movie the
movie's so good go watch this in a
theater bring someone you love and then
i'll be waiting for you here to explain
the implications of all this first a
recap of this movie thor jane foster
valkyrie and korg visit omnipotent city
to seek help from zeus to deal with gore
the godbutcher who has been killing god
after god in the mcu and has recently
kidnapped the asgardian children from
new asgard these children including
heimdall's son astrid aka axel named
after axel rose and as they're headed
into omnipotent city thor actually name
drops other deities who will be here
including hercules a nasdaq god and many
others and when they arrive there's
actually a bunch of familiar faces the
great protector of talo from celestials
like the man celestial and the celestial
gardener a bow god they actually
mentioned an off-screen carpenter god
implying yeah jesus is a buchanan i mean
he always was you know the single set of
footprints in the sand and the like but
now we know that jesus is friends with a
bunch of a-holes and the fight that
ensues zeus crumbles korg but korg
survives because it's just a space
that's all he needs thor blows a hole
through zeus's chest and they steal
zeus's thunderbolt one weapon they know
can go toe-to-toe with gore's sword the
necro sword so they go on to confront
gore in the shadow realm where they
learned that all of this was gore luring
them into a trap just to steal
stormbreaker why because stormbreaker is
the powers of the bifrost and he needs a
bifrost rainbow bridge to access the
heart of eternity yes eternity the
cosmic entity from the marvel lore the
living embodiment of the universe itself
commonly depicted as a silhouette
containing stars and planets eternity in
this movie represents a kind of wish
fulfillment that gore initially wants to
use to kill all gods in one fell swoop
now eternity is the brother to infinity
whose statue head lined the chamber
where gore used stormbreaker to open
this portal we saw statues of infinity
and eon representing time lady death the
living tribunal the ultimate legal
authority and the watcher actually when
gore initially arrived there was also a
statue of a head of a celestial and i
believe this is the one above all
considered to be the highest rating
celestial but that statue head gets
smashed thor tells it gets to pick up
the various pieces of all this rubble
and he declares an odin style charm to
give each kid the power of thor this is
basically the logic for why mjolnir
protected jane and responded to her jane
joins thor in this battle despite the
power-ups resetting her cancer
treatments they're able to overwhelm
gore and as his life fades through him
he makes it to the other side of the
eternity portal where eternity sits
silently in a meditative state gore
instead uses eternity to regenerate his
unnamed daughter who died in the opening
scene who's actually played by chris
hemsworth's real life daughter india
rose hemsworth and asgore dies and as
jane dies thor promises to look after
this girl leading to the final scene
where thor and his foster daughter
charged into battle this girl carrying
stormbreaker thor carrying mjolnir once
more as korg's storytelling narration
throughout the film in the final line
nicknames them love and thunder and yes
i got emotional i just want a daughter
so bad now it is not specified but the
implication here is that since gore's
daughter was reborn from eternity she
may actually be the mcu's version of
mistress love or just love another
abstract concept embodied in a living
form within the marvel hierarchy she's
ranked below eternity infinity but above
galactus and the celestia we talked
about the one above all i may be reading
into the semantics too much but korg's
narration does say she was born from
eternity now the first post-credits
scene returns to omnipotent city where
zeus wallows in defeat with his wound
being tended to by these women whom the
credits call his zeus and he laments the
fallen status of gods in the universe
saying in russell crowe's amazing greek
accidents movie they beg you for mercy
without them knowing if you are actually
listening now when they look to the sky
they don't ask us for lightning they
don't ask for rain they just want to see
one of their so-called superheroes when
did we become the joke no no more they
will fear us again when thor odinson
falls from the sky and then zeus looks
upward and asks do you understand me my
son and then we cut to hercules played
by brett goldstein best known as the
lovably gruff roy kent from ted lasso he
stands and grunts yes father and he
brandishes his iconic weapon for the
marvel comics the golden mace it's made
out of adamantine not adamantium
adamantine and forged by hebestus and
this weapon is considered to be as
strong as mjolnir hercules of course
comes from greek mythology the son of
zeus an immortal woman and one of the
great heroes known for his 12 labors in
marvel comics he was a long time rival
to thor and a later friend who joins the
avengers during civil war hercules
joined team cap against superhero
registration he actually killed the thor
cyborg considering it an insult to
odinson he's a major figure in secret
invasion in a dark reign and in world
war hulk actually in addition to being a
rival with thor he's also considered a
strength rival to hulk we don't really
know who's stronger between the two of
them also in world war hulk he teams up
with a young amadeus cho really he's
seen as the bad boy to thor's golden boy
maybe too soon to see him in secret
invasion but a future thor team up the
credits do promise thor will return or
in avengers secret wars maybe even a
world war hulk title wherever we see
this guy again bless my soul perk will
make a troll now if you're full of
chivalry and really want to address
someone as lord and lady established
titles can make it official established
titles is a project based on a historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or lords and
ladies in english they let people buy as
little as one square foot of dedicated
land so that they can call themselves a
lord or lady and in return established
titles commits to planting a tree it's a
really fun way to help preserve the
beautiful woodlands and biodiversity of
scotland while supporting global
affordation efforts established titles
work with global charity trees for the
future and one tree planted to help them
plant a tree for every order plus for
those with scottish heritage out there
it's just a great way to connect to your
family roots your certificate features a
unique plot number with which you can
see the exact location of your land on a
private estate in edelston scotland and
an official certificate with a crest you
can get a couple pack for you and your
partner with adjoining plots of land and
you can literally have this gift ready
in five minutes so what makes an amazing
last minute gift and established titles
is actually running a massive sale right
now plus if you use the code new
rockstars you get an additional 10 off
so go to established establishtitles.com
new rockstars to get your gifts now and
help support this channel now the second
postcarded scene catches up with jane
foster after she disintegrated into gold
sparkle dust upon her death this is the
same form odin took when he died when
frigga took when she died and when all
the gods died in this movie and now we
see where they go jane arrives in
valhalla this is of course the norse
afterlife that's been mentioned
throughout these films but never shown
until now and she's greeted by heindal
both are rogued and healthy looking and
the terrain of valhalla is depicted as
something like new asgard a rocky
norwegian fjord this actually looks like
the terrain that was in the background
of all the posters that were released
and seeing valhalla as a physical realm
is just interesting considering the
growing importance of realms as opposed
to universes in the mcu recently
explored on ms marvel with the nord
dimension and on moon night with the
duat underworld and in chiang chi with
talo in the realms beyond and of course
in the black panther films the ancestral
plain moon knight just established that
the wakandan ancestral plane and the
egyptian duat were part of the same
spiritual afterlife network in the mcu
which now presumably includes valhalla
as well as other realms that have been
mentioned like thanos's soul realm the
mirror dimension the astral plane the
gap junction and the quantum realm which
of course is going to come back in
ant-man the wasp quantomania so what
separates realms from universes is that
universes are really parallel timelines
to our own they have the same general
geography and architecture and alternate
versions of us just with certain
variables swapped between them but
realms are otherworldly dimensions with
surreal physical properties and
fantastical beings and structures realms
are suggested to be the buffer zones
between universes like the mirror
dimension they exist all around us and
realms are accessed via death or by
hidden waypoints and again we did meet
some realm based beans in chongqi and
yes the clandestines of ms marvel and we
brought this up before but the quantum
realm does contain a city in the
background a city that will probably
explore in quantum mania and remember
when loki entered the void in loki
episode four in five initially thought
it was hell with one l hell is the norse
afterlife the negative punishment based
inverse of valhalla in our world
mythology this is actually where
christianity derived its notion of hell
hell with two elves so the point of the
scene isn't just to give jane and
heindall and presumably also odin and
frigga and valkyrie's past girlfriend a
kind of happy ending as they sail into
the sunset like frodo and bilbo but
actually to further establish in the mcu
a life after death in a growing network
of realms as spiritual afterlifes when
certain characters die in the mcu they
pass on to these realms in the ragnarok
event in the comics as guardian souls
are actually reincarnated into new
corporeal bodies so we may yet learn of
an mcu reincarnation system where souls
do not die and disappear forever but
actually go through some kind of
transition process where they initially
go to realms a kind of purgatorial state
and then maybe get reincarnated into new
bodies in separate universes this could
be how we get new recasted forms of
characters like tony stark or t'challa
hell maybe this is something wanda
maximoff is currently going through in
hell currently meeting a new friend
before she resurrects in a new form let
me know your thoughts about these scenes
in the comments below follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you